was there a young thing that you did
when you were a child like a in young
love like some like
thing you guys did together like name um
oh bro i got one what is it in my my old
hometown room on the ceiling there's
like those little like neon like
glow-in-the-dark stars oh yeah yeah and
they're still there
but
and they should be
the best is when they're still there
when you're 30 dude oh bro i was back
over the holidays you turn the lights
off smoke a little bit of that kush and
you look up and you're like is that
[ __ ] orion's about
just a ceiling fan but when i was
younger in like sixth grade i would like
name the stars after the girls like
crushes on i'll be like that's krista
ooh and and that like you know you're
listening to me he was [ __ ] [ __ ] but
that like like there was something about
that that i was like damn
i just it brought me it was like hearing
goodies by sierra for the first time
every time
that was one thing that i that i
that i think i would that i did you know
that's beautiful you got anything like
that i got there was this girl chrissy
that i was in love i don't know if i was
in love with her but she lived close
enough for me to be horny about
which was the same thing you know what
i'm saying but i was blocked yeah oh god
i remember just everything about her
just
just god made just
just made semen want to climb out of my
body you know i want to take a peek oh
like a gopher seeing if his groundhog's
there or not oh you'd probably hear a
team and just come up to the top of my
tongue and just look out you know i'm
saying like roll back down or they go
get the home he's like you got to see
this [ __ ] yeah with us right homie let's
ride and did and you just thought about
her or are you
you guys want
i was in love with her and you went on a
couple dates with her we were children
they didn't have dates they didn't have
any we played it huh play date no no no
we live near there's no play dates in my
[ __ ] neighborhood dude people getting
molested
i i lived in a very uh suburban town
yeah this is way different dude played
age you know juice box guy down the
street used to bang this substitute
teacher that lived in our neighborhood
this kid basically was 16. yeah and then
he would chase us around in the church
like field with his car in his car and
tried to hit us
that was a date right there that was a
play day
yeah
so basically this dude was getting
molested by an older woman and then
since we called him out
like uh you just try to run over so he
just turned that [ __ ] into grand theft
auto just a little bit of gta in real
life
yeah there was no play date don't you
want you know one kid that
drooled all the time
that we would all kind of spend time
with but i think that was more like a
cry for help i think than anything but
um
what was i gonna tell you about oh so
oh but i was in love with this girl
chrissy bro god
and i remember she had part of her tooth
was chipped out yeah you know she had
that little baby lloyd christmas on her
you know love it and i remember always
looking for pieces of rock or shell when
i was like outside of the schoolhouse
like when they had uh oh all the gravel
yeah trying to find one that would be
like the cinderella
yeah
uh i found a couple i remember
collecting five or six that were pretty
close yeah i showed her one time
somebody locked us in a room like you
guys need to get in there and [ __ ] you
know just something you know even better
rocks
probably some local 40 year old you know
the same guy driving around in the car
bro there was so many creeps man and did
any of them fit or not
or did she like take any of them or she
like yeah i gave them all to her wow i
think she thought it was sweet
i would i think it's sweet now i was
hearing about that you know i put it on
a pukeshell necklace
oh yeah i thought i had that ability to
make them necklace kits you know yeah
that was always if somebody if a girl
likes somebody a lot of time they would
get that necklace kid and put the thing
randy you know and spell it out you get
that thing that we had a dumb one where
if you take the inside of like an
aquafina water bottle the cap it's like
a plastic and you like you can make the
plastic a wristband and the weird joke
was like if they put it on you and it
broke you had to like make out with them
oh really so you were always praying at
break you like tensing up your knuckles
you sneeze extra hard oh [ __ ] i guess we
gotta make out no mag but yeah the
inside of an aquafina cap is like a
little rubber thing you can poke out the
center make a little wristband but you
see a kid like maybe a guy who like
probably has a couple of like
misdemeanors now but he'd have like
three wristbands on him growing up and
you're like dude [ __ ] got some puss
this morning
that was yeah i feel like growing up was
always just a way to flex you know just
like having a girl wear your football
jersey
you know you walk to school with a
hickey everybody wore tank tops on
hickey day we caught two dudes sucking
on each other's necks doing fake hickeys
on each other one time
oh yeah damn but had they not got caught
with a [ __ ] legend then they would
have [ __ ] each other
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you